bonjour à tous je suis c'est 'qui
l'attaquent tech
aujourd'hui vous l'aurez compris nous
allons parler du rôle d'un avocat
alors c'est quoi un avocat l'avocat est
quelqu'un qui connaît bien les lois et
les tribunaux c'est un auxiliaire de
justice qui en forment les personnes
afin de leur éviter d'aller au tribunal
il a également les personnes qui sont
convoqués on distingue trois catégories
d'avocats les avocats d'affaires dont
les clients sont des entreprises les
pénalistes qui défendent notamment les
auteurs présumés de crimes ou délits
les spécialistes des affaires civiles
qui se chargent des divorces ou des
successions par exemple l'avocat est
soumis au secret professionnel
il est notre confident et on peut se
confier à lui son qu'il répète ce qu'on
lui a dit il peut conseiller les
individus les entreprises les
collectivités et les administrations
pourquoi les avocats sont ils
nécessaires mais ici personne n'est
censé ignorer la loi elle reste assez
complexes et multiples et surtout elles
évoluent souvent
l'avocat est un professionnel qui
connaît tous ces changements et il a
pour vocation de défendre les personnes
dans les litiges de la vie courante
il est important d'avoir quelqu'un pour
nous expliquer le vocabulaire juridique
et la procédure pour nous accompagner
dans les différentes étapes comme par
exemple nous informer sur nos droits sur
le fonctionnement des tribunaux et sur
ce qui est permis de faire ou de dire
pour nous défendre
ensuite l'avocat doit nous représenter
il agit donc en notre nom pour résoudre
notre problème juridique
il va discuter avec nous pour collecter
des éléments utiles à notre cause
cherchez des lois et présenter des
arguments pour nous défendre par écrit
et oralement
enfin il te cherchais des décisions de
justice relatives à une question
juridique donnée c'est la jurisprudence
mais l'avocat peut aussi nous aider dans
d'autres domaines par exemple rédiger
des actes juridiques comme des contrats
des transactions ou tout simplement
discuter avec la partie adverse pour
essayer de régler le litige à l'amiable
et éviter ainsi le prophète est ce que
tout le monde a le droit d'être défendu
par un avocat
la loi impose le respect des droits de
la défense c'est à dire que toute
personne a droit à l'assistance d'un
conseil et d'être représenté par un an
ok même les enfants mineurs peuvent
disposer de leur propre avocat pour
défendre leurs intérêts par exemple dans
le cadre des audiences du juge aux
affaires familiales comme avocat fixe
ses propres zones horaires et peu
importe l'issue du procès mais un avocat
d'office peut vous être désigné si vous
n'avez pas les moyens nécessaires et
s'il s'agit d'une affaire impliquant un
mineur d'ailleurs des consultations
gratuites d'avocats peuvent être
organisées au sein des mairies des
tribunaux d'instance et des tribunaux de
grande instance et concrètement à la
réunion où est ce qu'on peut trouver des
avocats pour obtenir la liste des
avocats
il faut s'adresser au secrétariat du
tribunal de grande instance de
saint-denis et de saint-pierre
j'espère que vous avez bien compris
l'importance des avocats dans notre
société qui est régie par les lois
à bientôt pour un nouvel épisode
fin